what is happening there reject nation
greg here today
e3 is going on and apparently there's a
game that i did not know about that
they made marvel's guardians of the
galaxy world premiere trailer e3
2021 just me today john is uh
having his his own relaxing day to
himself for his birthday
so yep let's see what's in store
some guardians of the galaxy maybe it'll
be you know
better than the avengers game or
be as good depending on your subjective
opinion if you actually
enjoyed that game
[Music]
i am so proud of you
do you know what a birthright is peter
star-lord's mom okay
yes familiar team
gardeners of the galaxy no rocket
so i let groom fill out the
[Laughter]
need a paperwork
it's a car to suggest
[Music]
dude look straight up like troy bakery
he looks
are you do you only play a star lord in
this
hey
coming out sooner than i expected just
in a few months from now
damn what i've been trying to say this
whole time there's so much
so much dialogue in this trailer
throughout every time i they cut the
drax like i kept thinking of the older
versions of
of kratos from god of war that's just
what he looks like
not a hundred percent but that's where
my mind went uh yeah the game looks cool
the game looks like a lot of fun
it looks like very similar in terms of
the
avengers game except it's the guardians
of the galaxy world
uh you know you're instead of a bunch of
robots you're gonna be fighting like a
bunch of different
alien creatures and stuff and perhaps
encounter cosmo the space dog i mean the
thing that
gets me optimistic about this it's
guardians of the galaxy
so there's so much to mine from there's
so much you can explore when you think
about the potential
of the cosmos wow there's so much
creative ingenuity you can do with this
game and so much you can explore
so many cool villains you could go up
against and it's just kind of the matter
of oh yeah how will the gameplay feel
and also um will they
really commit to doing all that and it
looks like there's a wide variety of
levels and layers to explore within this
game
so that's what looks cool it lends
itself to a little bit more variety
and and it seems to be capturing the
spirit between like the camaraderie of
the whole team it seems to be capturing
the spirit of what the
chemistry was on display with the actors
in the movie itself
i guess what i was kind of expecting at
least was sort of hoping they would do
you know how there's like the marvel
spider-man game that
most people seem to really love how that
doesn't seem like it's based
on any particular movie it seems like
they're actually doing it
its own thing and just going off of the
comics making their own adaptation with
the game
it felt like kind of with the avengers
game with the with the main set of
characters i'm talking about not
necessarily plot but the main set of
characters and then over here too
that they are doing like adaptations
of the marvel movie versions of these
characters
and doing their own story with it when i
really just want them to
truly embrace doing a little bit more of
their own thing because it's like yeah
the exact team here is the one from
guardians of the galaxy the live-action
movie
and i think it'd be pretty cool if you
had like other players here the bits of
gameplay from my understanding i think
they did release an actual gameplay for
um
this this uh this this game that's the
end of the sentence yeah that's what it
is but the trailer is
communicating to me at least is that you
only play a star lord that says
right there you you you are star-lord
which
is a bit of a detractor for me because
it's
guardians of the galaxy and part of the
allure same thing it's like imagine if
you only got the avengers game and
you're like you can only play as iron
man like you can't play as anybody else
you'd want to be able to play as all of
them is it one of those things where
every level they're all together and
it's like star-lord is a lead and you
can
uh sort of like get assist or command
from your other players that's a that's
a bit of the vibe that
emily's picking up on from what they're
pitching here which i guess separates
the gameplay from avengers i don't know
maybe like
the dlc maybe you by the time you beat
the game you unlock them and you're able
to
play as all of them because yeah right
now what they're showing here with this
trailer
it does feel like the tone of the movie
it's capturing the
the life of all that from all the
characters i don't know who the voice
actors are i want to say he's troy baker
because he looks like
troy baker and i know there are some
people who are pretty big defenders of
the uh defenders another marvel there
are some people who are pretty big
defenders of
the avengers video game that came out as
a matter of fact i was just hanging out
with a friend last night he was saying
yeah i love the game reminds me of like
good old-fashioned buttermash and he
plays it a lot i know more people who
who don't love the game so i don't know
how much
of the reaction to that particular
installment in these marvel games and
square enix are going to
affect how this game ultimately unfolds
i feel like spider-man's insomniac game
just really set a high bar
when you have this ensemble of
characters to play from
where you know it's capable of telling a
rich story it's like you want them to
come
close to at least matching that bar this
one right now
feels like other than the disappointing
element that you can't play as are the
other people not 100
about that this is what the trailer
seems to be telling me it looks uh it
looks like a lot of fun
and hopefully the graphics uh are even
better by the time the game comes out
holding out optimism because honestly
right now the trailer to me was it's
okay it's not
anything great not anything really
special to me but it's
it's okay it looks like it has potential
because it's guardians of the galaxy
but right now it yeah it looks uh looks
looks like looks like a fun game but not
one i might fully commit my heart to
to to see through till the end but guys
what do you think about the trailer
curio but guys what do you think about
the trailer curious to know subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button
and we'll check you guys out soon
you